hey this may or may not surprise some of
you yet another Republican has been
found guilty of voter fraud and you know
I saw the headline former New York
election official pleads guilty to
ballot fraud
I knew it was going to be a republican
but I figured I should look at the
article just to make sure and of course
it was Jason Schofield a republican who
recently resigned from the Rensselaer
County Board of Elections in New York
admitted he applied for absentee ballots
using other people's per other voters
personal information
he pleaded guilty yesterday to applying
for absentee ballots in the names of
others he's from Troy New York he
resigned last month and he admits back
in 2021 he unlawfully used the names and
birth dates of Voters in connection with
12 absentee ballot applications that he
electronically submitted to the New York
State voter absentee ballot application
request portal portal he's 43 years old
he admits he falsely certified that he
was those 12 different people he was
originally arraigned in September his
attorney said showfield maintained his
innocence in the 12-count indictment
he's scheduled to be sentenced May 12th
he faces up to five years in prison a
fine of a quarter million dollars and
supervised release of up to three years
for each count the really important
takeaway here continues to be individual
voter fraud of this kind is very very
rare in the United States there's a
study by the Brennan Center for justice
voter fraud occurs at a rate of less
than
0.0003 percent
that's like one case of fraud for every
30 million votes that are cast and other
Studies have found the same however
when we do find stories of individual
voter fraud aside from being really rare
they are mostly Republicans and it's a
really terrible way to try to win
elections and the reason is that the
scale is so small and the risk's so big
voter fraud of this kind often involves
one or a few people trying to sway the
outcome of an election at least in
theory and even if they get away with
their small-scale voter fraud the impact
on the overall results would rarely be
significant now if it's a really really
really tiny election you know a town of
800 people in which only a fraction are
adults and only a fraction vote and it
could come down to five votes and you do
this with 12 ballots maybe you can swing
an election insanely unlikely and the
risk is too high they love to say we
have no way of catching these people we
seem to catch plenty of them and they
almost exclusively are Republicans who
are either trying to test the system or
are saying it's actually Democrats who
are doing it so another case relatively
rare
but it just so happens that it's yet
another Republican sentencing in May
we'll see if they throw the book at him
which would mean five years and that
would be pretty interesting to see I
must say